John Doerr why didn't you perform comedy
I perform comedy who's gonna be in black
and white by the way can be until you
can I mean it I think would be nice yeah
I'm starting to feel like maybe huh
you know it should be in black and white
I perform comedy I guess because I know
some people cannot I have a voice I can
speak for those who can't speak because
I want to change the world I want it to
be a better place
they're not gonna tackle issues that are
important to people get off this stage
Allanon show has always been quite good
to me they've really let me run wild you
know it's rained on me one point I was
sitting at Conan's desk this is great
crazy stuff I mean sir groundbreaking
yeah sure and what's different about
this routine there's a lot of moving
parts
we'll say that okay it was an incredible
process many departments had to come
together hair and makeup in the music
department as well
sound effects every department was
moving on this piece Rob I'm gonna go
ahead and give you a couple different
versions here integrity integrity
integrity in Tegrity integrity integrity
integrity the wardrobe department
fantastic visionaries okay so now bend
over bro all right now back up
now a lot of people I think could could
pull something like this off God gave me
this talent and I can't waste it I have
a great opportunity and I would never
take it for granted
[Applause]
you